this church is now
home for hundreds of people who fled
mount neregongo
africa's most active volcano
some of their homes were destroyed by an
eruption last week
others followed the army's order to then
evacuate the city of gomer
in the democratic republic of congo
esperanza mushika
is one of several people here who told
us they lost their children
in the panic i was on my way out to buy
flour when i saw the fire
my children were out playing we all ran
away i don't know where they went
later i was told they were in a car
accident trying to escape
but i can't find them in the hospitals
or morgues they were declared missing
and i'm yet to find them
it's got to be hard to find anyone here
in the town of sake
it's overrun just down the road from the
church these people are waiting for food
it's the first help they've been given
since they arrived four days ago
right now the level of the crisis
is high because people have gone without
food
they have been relying on others to help
them
they are hungry people
they're thirsty too there's just
this one water point that's now being
shared by hundreds of people
they're queuing up waiting their turn to
try and get water to drink
and for cooking the conditions aren't
really clean at all here
the latrines that belong to the local
community aren't nearly enough
for all the people that have arrived
here the local administrator has said
that they've already detected
several cases of cholera meanwhile
esperanza has found a glimmer of hope
somebody called her from gomer saying
they've seen her children
near her home it's a 20 kilometer ride
back to the city
rocks formed from lava from past
eruptions
cover her neighborhood it's near the
foot of the volcano
in the red zone not a safe place
for missing children in an eruption
but she's in luck
i have so many things to say i'm happy
to see them and i'm grateful they're
alive
they didn't die
one family happily reunited
many more are still not malcolm webb
al jazeera gomer democratic republic of
congo